il est 5h du matin ce matin on a été
réveillé par des tirs et en fait on est
descendu un petit peu notre rue avec
des forces de l'ordre absolument partout
[Musique]
les jeunes qui les ont caillassé parce
que la situation va sûrement se pendre
dans les heures qui viennent
en fait à Mayotte la violence c'est
quelque chose de quotidien pour les
habitants le taux de criminalité il a
explosé ces dernières années sur l'île
et là l'État français a décidé de réagir
c'est des moyens que vous puissiez vivre
en sécurité et soyez assuré la France
c'est l'insécurité il y a des vidéos
d'agression qui tournent en boucle sur
les réseaux sociaux par exemple ici
c'est un bus scolaire qui est pris
d'assaut par un groupe de jeunes armée
de machette tout ça pour voler des
téléphones portables et les habitants de
Mayotte ils sont à bout ils veulent vous
prendre votre argent votre chat tout ce
que vous avez comme appareil photo ou
autre la France se fait se fait baiser
par les Comores
ceux qui sont visés ici ce sont les
étrangers qui viennent majoritairement
des Comores qui sont des îles voisines
qui sont à seulement quelques kilomètres
de Mayotte c'est
CAFAL que de nous tuer ici
tout ce qui se passe en maillot d'ici là
en ce moment c'est les mots contre les
Comoriens ça c'est la guerre civile qui
va être là
la tension elle est extrême à Mayotte et
la malgave entre délinquants et
étrangers je l'ai vraiment très souvent
entendu là-bas alors ce que j'ai voulu
vous raconter dans cette vidéo sont
l'histoire de plusieurs jeunes qui ont
l'impression d'être les boucs émissaires
de tous les problèmes qui aujourd'hui à
Mayotte alors ces jeunes ne se sentent
français même si leurs parents viennent
des Comores à l'origine et ils sont eux
aussi victimes de la sécurité qu'il y a
sur l'île vous allez faire la
connaissance de yanine et de Mohamed
Mohamed sa vie a été complètement
bouleversée le jour où ses parents ont
été expulsés vers les Comores il a
grandi à Mayotte seul à la rue depuis
qu'il a 14 ans
mais son quartier il est menacé de
destruction parce qu'il est considéré
comme un bidonville et en fait quelqu'un
le plus c'est de se retrouver dans la
même situation que moi-même parce que
ses parents ils ont pas la nationalité
française donc ils peuvent être expulsés
du jour au lendemain alors que ça fait
40 ans qu'ils vivent à Mayotte
aujourd'hui Yannick elle a 19 ans et
elle passe son bac à la fin de l'année
et toi tu as toujours grandi ici oui
j'ai grandi ici en fait depuis tout
petit je suis né dans ce dans ce
quartier j'ai grandi ici je veux mes
premières dents j'ai fait mes premiers
pas donc si je pars d'ici ça va faire un
gros choc vu que j'ai grandi ici
pour les profs on s'en bat les couilles
tu as pas les papiers là tout de suite
et vous pensez quoi l'opération déjà il
faut qu'ils arrêtent de penser à ça
qu'ils oublient carrément qu'on existe
et qu'il me reste tranquille en paix ici
tout le monde ne se plaint pas en fait
personne ne se plaint d'être habité ici
[Musique]
est-ce que ça te fait déjà arrivé de
faire des choses que tu regrettes des
choses pas bien parce que tu avais trop
faim
Google
et à Mayotte tu aurais près de 4000
mineurs isolés dans la même situation
que lui et donc les services sociaux ils
sont complètement débordés et c'est
cette vie de galère à la rue qui
pourrait attendre yanine si son quartier
est détruit et ses parents expulsés
[Musique]
quand on était petit ça c'est la chambre
de mon grand frère c'est lui qui est
notre pied là-bas
et ça
ça on vient pour prier parce que nous on
est des musulmanes on vient pour prier
quelques à chaque heure
ici c'est pour
comment dire c'est pour ne pas être trop
à l'intérieur de la maison parce qu'il y
a un moment il fait trop chaud donc on
vient ici pour s'aérer
là-bas c'est la cuisine on a deux
toilettes de toilette après c'est le
salon ouais même si c'est ça non c'est
pas forcément
ici c'est le salon la chambre de mon
père ma chambre est celle de ma petite
sœur c'est pas vraiment très grand mais
je m'y plais quand même c'est chez moi
je me suis habitué donc
aller dans un autre endroit que je
connais pas je connais à peine ça va ça
va bouleverser ça
va mieux faire
tout bizarre
donc ici c'est la maison de votre enfant
oui on a grandi ici donc
moi je suis carrément
je ne comprends pas il y a une comme la
majorité des habitants qui vivent ici
dans ce quartier ont des documents
officiels qui leur donnent
l'autorisation de vivre sur ce terrain
depuis des années Mohamed lui il a pas
de logement il a pas de famille non plus
et on le retrouve un soir dans un des
quartiers les plus pauvres de Lille
moi je ne sais pas parce que pas la
police il me voit moi il cause tu vois
toujours
ah ouais c'est comme ça c'est mon
quartier
après moi je suis resté avec mes amis
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
tu penses à tes parents parfois
mon futur
ses parents ils sont morts en fait en
faisant naufrage alors qu'ils essayaient
de revenir à Mayotte par bateau les
petits bateaux qu'on appelle des
croissants pour venir récupérer leur
fils justement et depuis un Mohamed il
jongle entre la rue les familles
d'accueil la débrouille mais il n'a
jamais réussi à avoir ses papiers
français et là il vient tout juste
d'avoir 18 ans donc il peut être expulsé
à n'importe quel moment alors qu'il ne
connaît personne au Comores et qu'il n'y
a jamais vécu
donc là j'ai d'abord le café de Magic
avant qui encerclé par la gendarmerie
depuis ce matin donc pour le moment il
en a me parlent d'une mission de
sécurisation et de contrôle identité
donc il s'est acheté à savoir qui est
français qui ne l'est pas pour être
expulsé du territoire alors j'ai eu
Yannick au téléphone apparemment ils
sont rentrés dans les maisons pour leur
dire qu'il fallait partir qu'il fallait
faire des affaires que le quartier très
détruit notre très peu de temps
enlève leur leurs affaires leurs meubles
parce qu'ils ont très peur qu'ils soient
détruits par les machines de la
gendarmerie comme vous pouvez voir juste
ici donc les gens ici ils sont
complètement démunis ils sont en train
de faire leurs valises ils savent pas du
tout où aller
en fait on est rue du quartier on peut
voir c'est des numéros inscrits à la
bombe de peinture un peu partout sur les
murs des maisons en fait sur les
autorités publiques qui ont recensé
toutes les habitations et les habitants
du quartier avant la démolition
et regardez les plans ça
les commencé à faire des grabouillis et
tout et vous vous allez aller où du coup
on cherche on cherche on est en train de
chercher
[Musique]
et ton père ça fait combien de temps
qu'il vit ici 39 ans
de plus il est frustré
c'est juste faute
et sa famille comme beaucoup d'autres
habitants du quartier ils ont des
compteurs d'eau d'électricité et fait
leur facture c'est pourquoi en fait
beaucoup d'habitants ont décidé de
porter plainte au tribunal qu'on fait à
valoir l'endroit et éviter que leur
quartier soit détruit
je me trouve actuellement devant le
tribunal administratif de Mamoudzou et
une audience qui est actuellement en
cours parce qu'il y a une vingtaine
d'habitants du quartier et de Magic à
veau qui ont saisi la justice
la situation des familles a été
envisagée pour mettre à la vie
à la sortie de cette audience j'ai voulu
faire une interview des avocats qui
défendent gratuitement les habitants du
quartier de yanine et en fait aucune
d'entre elles n'a souhaité répondre
devant une caméra pour une raison assez
dingue c'est qu'en fait elles ont très
peur des représailles et une partie de
la population de Mayotte qui leur
reproche de défendre ce que eux
appellent des criminels qui viennent de
l'étranger et donc elles sont très
souvent l'objet de menaces
[Musique]
le tribunal de sa réponse le quartier ne
sera pas détruit demain selon le juge
les conditions de relogement sont pas du
tout satisfaisantes et surtout
l'opération d'évacuation et de
distribution du quartier pourrait mettre
en péril la sécurité des habitants donc
les habitants ont un délai
supplémentaire alors l'État a fait appel
donc cette décision elle peut être bien
sûr modifiée elle peut changer elle peut
évoluer mais pour le moment pas de
destruction et pas d'évacuation
je suis en train de réviser le corriger
des textes qu'on a étudié à l'école en
classe
c'est facile de réviser dans ce contexte
non mais
[Musique]
ça fait chaud au cœur
c'est là où je me sens à l'aise c'est
mon chez moi c'est mon monde à moi
alors qu'est-ce que ça te fait quand tu
vois des hommes et des femmes politiques
qui disent que ce sont des criminels qui
vivent dans ces dans ces quartiers ça me
fait simplement parce que eux
ce qu'ils veulent c'est seulement
détruire et ils veulent atteindre leur
but avec tous les moyens qu'ils ont
mentir
accusé il y a pas de voyou qui qui se
taire ici comme comme il le disent je
sais pas pourquoi ils disent ils disent
ça
c'est même pas logique de dire ça
c'était même pas venu pour vérifier
toi-même
c'est très dur de d'être prise comme ça
alors qu'on est des humains on est tous
des hommes on aimerait être intégré dans
la société mais il nous sort de de la
société française
[Musique]
et toi c'est quoi ton rêve moi c'est
d'être un prof ça dépend j'ai plusieurs
rêves donc je vais me mettre à réfléchir
ça dépend mais j'aimerais juste avoir
une vie simple et normale et non de
chamboulement comme quoi on va nous
faire déménager décidément il y a trop
de il y a trop de de choses à réfléchir
et à trop de choses à nous casser la
tête en plus
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce reportage
j'espère qu'il vous a plu et surtout que
vous avez appris des choses c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à la partager et à vous
abonner et je vous dis à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]